i am extending you the warm invite of
inviting me
mm-hmm to japan to your family you are
inviting
me to invite you i'm inviting you
i'm inviting you to invite you how
generous
hello we are alex hashtag
alex back again with another japanese
cooking video it's been a while
yeah i haven't learned any more japanese
since the last time
what what did you think i did yeah
watashi
alex
we wanted to make it a little bit harder
for you
i cannot tell you yes or no like last
time
oh my god wait that was like how i did
it though
and i'm not gonna say oh you did this
wrong that is not
onion that it's not garlic i really
don't see you
create your creation okay okay cool
you know my confidence went from here to
about here you can do it do you remember
let's do it in japanese
[Music]
it sounds like gumballs
in front of you there are ingredients
are there
wait is this italian dude okay this is
all we need
right to make this challenge a little
bit more
interesting i put some trick ingredients
i will go through ingredients do i get a
notepad can i take notes
mushroom ketchup ketchup
these are great really helpful
hachimitsu
hachimitsu a little harder pasady
parsley
because i know negi is the green onion
oh why whenever i go to like a japanese
restaurant
i think my knowledge is more from menus
probably avocado avocado
truthfully i'm a little confused this
doesn't give me japanese vibes
but we'll see what happens do you think
we're just making like
mayonnaise mushrooms maybe
gumbo
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
i think the way to remember is literally
through song oh
okay so it's going to be a whole musical
the whole thing
oh
what that'd be more strict more more
strict
i don't know if i can take it okay all
right
cut it dice it i'm assuming it's going
to be a dice keep there
[Music]
peeling the onion naturally okay
i'm gonna slice it up put it in a bowl
bacon oh we didn't say the bacon in the
ingredients right
she's trying to fake me out
bacon hi now this makes way more sense
kidding i'm completely stumped okay
i can't even count in english oh god
this is so embarrassing
okay three slices of bacon bacon
cut it and dice it up like a little tiny
tsugi
sorry put it in a little bowl
now mushrooms is
because i'm going to tell you the truth
i will teach you
in english by accent mince the garlic
alex
oh it's not my head not the plugger
yeah oh see if it's hot oh it's kind of
cold it's not
yet
good blink once if it's a yes
so it's a no what was the question try
it out
try it out i don't know which i know i
need to turn it down a little
still let it get sauteed loosen up a
little and then i'm going to put in the
garlic
bacon bacon
mix it up smell it smell it
mushroom mushroom in japanese it's
kinoko
in general like general mushroom yeah
like shimeji
enoki it's like type of mushroom the
whole fungus
yeah kingdom yeah yeah yeah you know
there's some really interesting facts
about mushrooms
i don't know them off the top of my head
yeah but there are
nini the garlic
spaghettio spaghettios
this one hi that was a tricky ingredient
and spaghetti we are only here to use
spaghetti
alex
i'm doing a lot of things
you know what i'd love to do is go watch
the sumo
on me too i've never been what so maybe
we should go
okay we're going guys
one two three four five ten minutes okay
you're telling me the minutes
two minutes ichini sanchi go you know
okay
wow i know that one akka is red
oh sachi meat sauce you need one
tablespoon
of red wine i eyeball it no i could what
not in there thank you good
all right
it's
you would think that would help but it
doesn't one cup of ketchup
cheese
[Music]
japanese people love kitchen i know i do
know this
pasta
[Laughter]
okay oh that's for topping salt
hi hi hi let's do a little
spinny spin fancy fancy
beautiful make it rain
make it rain hi
[Applause]
in another life and i were clubbing in
japan
we were going to the sumo shows we were
eating ketchup mushroom pasta
it's on like donkey kong i don't get it
that's okay next time all right here's
mine
yeah there
it's like a fine dining restaurant like
a big place small potion i was trying to
be minimal
japanese minimal okay you remember like
when we make dona
we were opposites i made mine really big
my
left and should we eat
yours first okay so this dish is called
napolitan neopolitan it's popular in
japan like i grown up eating this
it does smell good yeah like i think the
red wine really comes through
the notes of ketchup cheers what do you
think
it's delicious ketchup naturally has a
nice like sweet
flavor yeah so the sauce is just like a
little bit sweeter than like
a basic red sauce how did i do i think
you did great i think it's very small do
you want to try mine
yeah it's very texturized and looking
like the visual
it's all the same digging in digging in
i got a nice piece of bacon in this one
it's so nostalgic just really works well
together
you wouldn't think like mushrooms and
bacon and
ketchup right we love like kind of sweet
tangy combination it's really good maybe
i need to
broaden my ketchup horizons so i provide
for the ketchup
i worked hard on this one mm-hmm and i
got to spend time with you yeah same
best thing it's so fun yeah air five ah
air wait ticcini go
[Music]
go
[Music]
you